[Music]
hey what's up guys of kabhi HD here and
a little do you know for the past week
I've been using this guy as my daily
driver so the day after 1:00 my blind
smartphone camera test I figured you
know what it's legitimately the People's
Choice so I might as well give it a shot
it is not coming to the u.s. officially
but I'm gonna try it anyway so I put my
sim card in the huawei mate 20 Pro and
this is the last phone to be reviewed
before the smartphone Awards and this
one's been getting a lot of hype I gotta
say I did that first impressions video
when it first came out that I sort of
laid off it and it slowly started
racking up phone of the Year awards and
it was people's Cop choices for 2018 so
I brought it back out the won the
contest so I gotta try it and I gotta
say I like it quite a bit now I don't
love it
and that that's really only because of
one thing but I like it a lot so here's
why yeah
we're off the bat while we've really
leveled up their design game with this
phone I think the hardware is on point
it's kind of closer to Samsung design
actually than anything with the shape of
the phone the glass on both sides
curving over the sides they're really
thin rails this is gonna be a slippery
phone without a case on it so I'm
warning you that right now but it does
have a slight texture like this subtle
raised pattern in the glass it's kind of
hard to describe
but it makes this sound when you drag
your fingernails across it I actually
like it to fix the slipperiness though
you might be better off covering it up
with a skin from our channel sponsor
addy brand personally I think going with
the red on the back even though it's a
little loud it matches the red power
button pretty well but they have plenty
of other options as well so of reds too
loud for you I'll link the rest of those
below but anyway yes I love the colored
power button that's a strong move right
there and then the triple cameras plus
the flash on the back kind of look like
bug eyes but I think in the middle it
looks fine and since the power and
volume buttons are all on one side the
left is totally smooth and blank but
yeah overall it just feels in the hand
like a galaxy s 9 has a baby with an
iPhone meaning you get mostly Samsung
design features and then that knotch
and then there's an IR blaster at the
top if you're into that I haven't had an
IR blaster and a phone in a really long
time but these used to be super useful
ip68 water resistance check USB C port
check in glass fingerprint reader check
thin bezels check speaker grille no
check so the speaker is actually behind
the USB C port in this phone so there's
no other speaker grille it seems like a
cool idea for about five seconds but
then it turns out to be a horrible idea
like the speaker's themselves aren't
that bad it's the one in the earpiece
and on the one at the bottom behind the
port but putting it behind the USB C
port makes it extremely easy to block
the whole thing by accident at any time
and even though I do mostly while I was
charging with this phone how do you
expect it to sound when you're plugged
in its muffled all the time so this
figure behind the port was not the move
otherwise though all-around great
hardware and then you get a great
display at the front too so a six point
four inch OLED and it's 31 20 by 1440 so
super sharp and it gets plenty bright in
daylight and like I said it has this
Samsung look so
shape sort of curves over on both sides
and then the back does it too and it
also has a notch up top which again at
this point I don't really mind anymore
almost every phone has one of some sort
plus you get all the same face ID
sensors so at least are using that space
well for something but the weird part is
on the size of the display there's this
little bit of light fall-off like it
gets a bit darker and discolored on the
very edges in a way that I don't think I
see really on samsung phones and there's
also a pretty obvious color shift off
axis like some other ohlet's it's a
pretty good display but it's not perfect
and then performance is great now again
since it's not coming to the US you'll
notice this is one of the few phones
that's not rocking a Qualcomm Snapdragon
chip it's actually the Kirin 980 so it's
a seven nanometer chip and there's six
gigs of RAM and 128 gigs of storage and
it's pretty smooth for the most part I'd
say on par with any Samsung phone like
an s9 or something no problems with
multitasking opening and closing apps
etc where the chip really shines however
is definitely battery life the best part
of this mate 20 pro 100% is not the
camera it is the battery so it's a 4200
milliamp hour cell even though the phone
is not that thick and why weighs power
management is pretty aggressive about
trying to save power it's changing the
resolution of the screen when you're not
using it much it's pretty pretty active
about killing apps in the background but
the result has been by far the best
battery life in any phone I've used this
year this has been a two-day phone for
me a couple times I don't get to say
that much so that's really impressive
a lot of the other flagships this year
that had the best battery life for my
heavy use we're getting like 5 to 6
hours of screen on time which is really
impressive May 20 protein a where I
ended with four and a half hours of
screen on time at about 1 a.m. and there
was 58% battery left Wow
I really do not ever think about
charging this phone there's constantly
more battery than I need I usually end
with 6 7 hours of screen on time before
I have to charge and when I do I pop it
on the wireless charger it's unreal this
is a no one can convince me this isn't
an a-plus-plus battery life phone and it
also has this head-turning feature
reverse wireless charging it is a
gimmick that all pretty much never use
but it
also hilarious and amazing and I'm glad
it works and I'm glad they did it
basically an extremely useful troll for
people and you also get to offer them a
charge but of course the most hyped part
about this phone was the camera and for
good reason so I rock and triple cameras
on the back with a flash you get a 40
megapixel main sensor an 8 megapixel
telephoto sensor and a 20 megapixel
super wide angle
those are big-boy numbers honestly to me
with the results it's an a-minus camera
meaning it's pretty good almost great
but not quite the best I definitely
sticks to what won the blind contest
which is bright photos pictures from the
may 20 Pro are often very bright
sometimes overexposed but it has good
enough dynamic range to not lose a bunch
of highlight detail and are basically
never any shadows now the detail on the
sharpness our A+ which I love to see and
the colors were a bit muted at times so
there's definitely a different sort of
color science with this Huawei
processing but really when there's a lot
of light there's just no contrast
absolutely no shadows no blacks when you
get down to low-light it holds up pretty
well though and this with the night mode
a little bit as well which did better
noise reduction but really the best part
about the camera is just the extra focal
lengths having that super wide angle
camera sometimes is pretty cool the
telephoto yeah less useful to me but I'm
glad it's there but really it's just
all-around super versatile and I don't
think anyone capable of a little photo
editing will really hate it and also
it's probably gonna end up the highest
ever
DxO mark score again if they ever review
it so if you care about that there you
go
so clearly there are a lot of reasons to
like this phone but I said at the
beginning there was something that
didn't quite measure up and for me
that's the software so this phone runs
emui on top of android pi so i'm glad
it's the latest version of android and
has all kinds of quirks and usability
things some of them are nice some of
them you may like but others I'm really
not into I'll be real I had to put a
little extra work to get it just the way
I want so I installed a Nova Launcher I
uninstalled a bunch of other duplicate
apps some others don't go away so I have
to disable them or hide them
I changed the keyboard I change the
default apps all kinds of stuff like
that sort of built my way into it it
takes more work for some phones
for others but I got it the way I wanted
and I've been using it and then there's
just a lot of bugs so the multitasking
one is my personal least favorite every
time I try to open the second most
recent app with one tap it just closes
multitasking not sure why it does that
and I hate it because that's something I
want to do all the time but it won't let
me the notification tray also is always
filled up even when I have no
notifications so if I get one or two I
don't know which ones they are and what
order they are unless I open the tray
and scroll down through them pour ease
of the notch there and you can disable
the knotch but as well doesn't fix that
problem and there's still all the
blatant copying of iOS this share sheet
with Huawei share instead of airdrop
still all that bloatware duplicate apps
all of that so I'm still not a fan of
the Mui that hasn't changed but
everything else about this phone is
really damn good the only downsides that
I can point to about the actual
physical hardware or the speaker like I
mentioned and the in glass fingerprint
reader is a little bit slow just like
the other first gen ones that are out
right now hopefully that will get faster
but the rest of the phone is very
complete I think I would love this phone
with oxygen OS or even pixels like stock
Android with a bunch of those features
but either way this is still the best
phone Huawei's ever made hands down
better than p20 pro and if you don't
mind paying the premium and importing it
then this is worth a look definitely
worth checking out either way that's
pretty much it I guess now that we've
reviewed this last phone we can dive
into the smartphone Awards for 2018
that's upcoming either way thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace